sometimes you know when you follow a
story for a while uh it's actually
rewarding it's actually rewarding
because you can see the evolution of
lies from people and that is exactly
what i have for you today the headline
is we have now learned
republican congressman jim jordan
did talk to donald trump
on the morning of the january 6 trump
riots
for at least 10 minutes straight just
the two of them on the phone
you might say
why is that a story it's a story because
for a year plus now
jim jordan has been deliberately
deceptive about his conversations with
donald trump on the day of the trump
riot so let's start with the news
newly obtained records
show trump and jim jordan spoke at
length on the morning of january 6th
the house select committee investigating
the insurrection now has records which
provide details about a phone call
donald trump made to jim jordan on
january 6th
two sources who reviewed the call
records tell cnn trump spoke on the
phone at the white house residence with
jordan for 10 minutes
on the morning of january 6. why do we
care about that we care about that
because we want to have jim jordan tell
us
what was trump planning what was trump
hoping would happen
on that day and for as long as jim
jordan says oh i don't know i don't know
if i spoke to him before or after
i don't know if i spoke to him at all no
i did but i'm not sure
we can
we have more trouble for to the extent
that we can't prove this conversation
took place
holding jim jordan accountable to get
him to either tell us what trump said on
that day or to say i'm gonna plead the
fifth or whatever the case may be a key
focus of the committee's investigation
has been on the run-up to the
insurrection and the myriad ways trump
and his allies including those in
congress
um
uh spoke to trump try to overturn the
election results the new details about
the morning phone call comes as the
committee is debating whether to move
forward with a subpoena for jordan after
he refused to voluntarily appear for an
interview so now we know
that he did speak to him on that morning
here is the
deceiving
constant
a back back story with jim jordan first
of all remember when he spoke to olivier
olivia beavers from politico
where he said quote look i definitely
spoke to the president that day
i don't recall i know it was more than
once i just don't recall the times
he was then asked about it by brett
bayer let's listen to what he had to say
then he's obviously going to go down a
number of different roads
about who knew what when who was talking
to coordinators of the protest did you
talk to the former president that day
i've talked to the former president
umpteen times thousands i mean i may not
i mean countless countless times i talk
to the president i never talk about what
we talk about but i just don't think
that's appropriate just like i don't
talk about what happens in republican
country now remember bret bayer didn't
ask what you talked about he said did
you talk to him on that day and jim
jordan says i've talked to him many
times
but i don't talk about what we talked
about the question was did you talk to
him on that day
so i've talked to the president numerous
times uh i continue to talk to the
president
on january 6 congressman yes i mean i've
talked to the president
i've talked to the president so many i
can't remember all the days i've talked
to him but i've certainly talked to the
president yeah and and on that day was
can you share any of the insight of what
he was thinking about that day
brett the people we need to come testify
are the people who can testify to the
fundamental questions why didn't the
united states capital the people's house
have an appropriate security posture now
what's funny is the committee has
decided jordan should testify but he's
refusing to go that day and what have we
done those are the people we need to
hear from those that's the information
testimony we need to get that's what we
should focus on but i don't think that
benny thompson the chairman of this
committee said everything's on the table
until we raise this issue about the
speaker's office is the one who knows
what what the security posture and why
it was the way it was okay so he didn't
answer um shortly thereafter a couple
weeks later he was then interviewed uh
again
and um this was on spectrum news and
just as evasive
there's some confusion over what you
told bret bear on fox news on tuesday
night so i want to clear it up first off
yes or no did you speak with president
trump on january 6th
yeah i mean i speak i spoke with the
president last week i speak with the
president all the time i spoke with him
on january 6. i mean i talk with
president trump all the time and that's
that's i don't think that's so here it
was no longer tenable to maintain he
didn't speak to trump on the 6th so so
here he conceded i did speak to him on
the 6th unusual uh i would expect
members of congress
to talk with the president of the united
states when they're trying to get done
the things they told the voters in their
district to do uh i i i'm actually kind
of amazed sometimes if people keep
asking this question of course i talk to
the president
the reason people keep asking is because
he was not directly saying i spoke to
him on january 6th i said i talked with
him last week on january 6 did you speak
with him before during or after the
capital was attacked
uh i'd have to go i i
i spoke with him that day after i think
after i don't know if i spoke with him
in the morning or not i i just don't
know uh he just doesn't know now it is
completely implausible
that
even if you bought at the time the first
time he was asked did you talk to him
that day
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
because this is how you have to think
about how absurd this was
imagine that jim jordan really speaks to
trump every day
and asked
a month later did you speak to him on
january 6th imagine he genuinely doesn't
remember i don't believe that for a
second i believe you remember but let's
give him the benefit of the doubt
once it is asked on fox news
and the answer is so obviously deceptive
there is no way in hell
that amongst his
you know
plentiful staff
no one comes to him and says sir
you spoke to trump
twice on january 6th including before
the riot so now you know
there is no way after that he doesn't
remember and here he is still saying i
just don't know was it before or after
now of course on a day that's that
momentous it's sort of like if i think
back to 9 11
right i remember where i was
and i can tell you with certainty what
happened after or before like if you say
to me did you work on the on 9 11. i
remember that yes i worked on 9 11. i
remember talking to my colleagues about
what was going on and so if you say and
were you at work at all before the
events took place i can say of course
not there was no period that day where
while at work i learned about what was
happening my entire day at work on 9 11
i was in high school at the time
was after the events took place when i
went in it was like are we even staying
open this is crazy etc there's no doubt
about it because it's a notable event
and so this idea that oh yeah well did
you speak to him at all before the riot
or
obviously the conversation would either
be what does trump expecting to happen
or what does trump react how is trump
reacting to what is happening
it's just completely implausible that he
doesn't remember i i have to go back and
i mean i don't i don't i don't know uh
though that when when those
conversations happen give me a button um
but what i know is i spoke him all the
time but but taylor the the key here is
the people we need to speak to
the people we need to talk to
are the ones who can answer the question
why wasn't there a better security
presence yeah no jim you're one of the
people that we actually need to be
talking to so
obvious liar obvious liar and now i mean
listen it took what it took 14 months
14 months we've been following this jim
jordan spoke to trump that morning
before the riot and so jim jordan could
tell us
did trump say anything about hoping that
there was violence
did trump say anything about what he was
expecting mike pence to do
this is the guy that we should be
talking to and they tried to talk to him
and he's refusing to appear
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video